les templiers sortent déjà des playoffs
de deuxième division ce samedi 25 mai
les élans courtois se sont inclinés en
demi-finale de conférence north face aux
gladiateurs de la queue-en-brie à
domicile malgré une légère avance à la
pause 7 à 3 et l'encours favori craque
finalement et perd 15 à 10 donc très
très grosse déception je pense que on
passe complètement à côté du match comme
on l'a dit en fait à la fin où des lots
joueurs en fait c'est nous qui donnons
le match on se tire des balles dans le
pied en fait tout simplement on a un
problème d'attitude de deux fautes
répétées qui
qui nous qui nous pourrissent la vie
depuis depuis quelques années il faut
vraiment qu'on règle le problème parce
que parce que c'est c'est trop triste
d'avoir un potentiel comme le nôtre et
de la loire des résultats en fait si
vous aussi mauvais cette défaite
condamne les élans courtois à rester une
année de plus en deuxième division une
quatrième saison consécutive pour se
relever de cette désillusion des
nouveaux axes de travail sont déjà
évoqués on verra ça cet été là je suis
vraiment j'accuse le coup donc on verra
ça puis un peu plus tard je pense d'ici
d'ici quelques semaines en réunion avec
les coaches avec les joueurs voir qu'on
se parle qu'on met les points sur les i
pour pouvoir repartir d'attac l'année
prochaine les templiers d'elancourt
reprendront le championnat de deuxième
division en janvier prochain l'objectif
devrait être une nouvelle fois la montée